let's return to the government's plans
for a points-based post brexit
immigration system under the new rules
which are due to be introduced in
January next year low-skilled workers
will be denied visas
well I'm joined now by brexit party
leader and former MEP Nigel Farage Mr
Farage thank you very much for joining
us in this morning we don't yet know
what the long and short term
consequences of this Points Based system
will be doing well what we do know is
it's a fundamental change what we do
know is we'll be treating people from
India in exactly the same way as people
from Romania that I think is absolutely
right and it's fitting with a global
Britain having left the European Union
the fact we're introducing criteria for
the you know who can come into the
country that also is a huge step in
there in the right direction something
the British public very much won so
they're the they're the big positives
from today the problem is the criteria
themselves suggests to me that the
numbers of people coming into the
country from outside the European Union
will be even bigger than they are
today and with no caps on numbers you've
got a possibility that this system means
more immigration not less this system
will come into effect in a year's time
or so I mean do you accept that there
will be pressures on the economy as
results look I know that every big
business wants as much cheap labor as
they can possibly get and they of course
don't give a damn about the community
about people's quality of life you know
one of the reasons brexit happened is
because people started to find it hard
to get their kids into the local primary
school to get an appointment at the
local GPs they saw huge changes taking
place in their towns and cities so the
truth of it is this is about numbers
numbers matter we've seen the British
population rise by 6 million since 2001
the vast majority of that because of our
immigration policies so people want a
proper system but they want numbers
reduced to it is about growth it is
about numbers is also bad our GDP and
many people say that this will result in
all of us being effective people from
all across the country do you know the
arguments these arguments that mass
migration has been good for GDP will
just look at our productivity our price
fact isn't it
our productivity is full
over the course of the last 20 years by
making ourselves the cheap labor capital
of Europe overall has not been a good
thing for our economy it's led to
significant de-skilling
and we now I've got to adopt a different
approach the G migrants making net
contribution see the UK economy that
just depends doesn't it but doesn't
doesn't increase doesn't it yeah and
this and this is that this is why
Westminster didn't understand why the
brexit vote was going to happen because
the conversation in stoke-on-trent is
not about where the GDP is up by 0.1
percent per annum because of an open
border policy it is about quality of
life it is about generally having
control over numbers coming into our
country and as I say you know this is a
step in the right direction but it's not
the full deal so why in your view is
this system fair well I think it was
wrong to discriminate against people
from India in favor of people coming in
from Romania absolutely crazy you know
we should have a global approach we
should be non-discriminatory in terms of
how we operate an immigration policy I
also think that to have you know a very
big flood and we did have a big flood of
unskilled and semi-skilled labor drove
down people's wages fundamentally change
the quality of life for millions of
people in this country so you're going
as the Australians do going with a set
of criteria that says you've got to be
skilled you've got to have the right
level of qualifications you're not going
to automatically qualify for free health
care all of those things are right but I
just think there needs to be a cap on
this okay you talk about discrimination
but under this new points-based system
Mr Farage a Bulgarian welder who holds
an a-level equivalence has a job offer
for 26,000 pounds a year doesn't speak
any English
would be allowed in this country an
Italian waiter who has a job offer in a
hotel at 20,000 pounds has a languages
degree and speaks fluent English
wouldn't be allowed in the country how's
that fair I am praising the fact that we
are putting some criteria in place we
probably have a wheeze probably we
probably well we probably haven't got
the criteria right but look it is much
better than having a complete open door
which we've had since 2004 which has and
I'm gonna repeat the point again has
actually lowered the quality of life for
millions of people in this country but
in the example that I've given you the
Bulgarian worker for example doesn't
speak any English how's that one quality
of life that no clapping down the
country look I understand the question
and you know pretty Battelle better
provide some answers on that do you
regret that poster that you put up about
the country being its breaking points I
can't regret the truth mrs. Merkel made
but it wasn't this truth because they
weren't Europeans come into the country
they were Syrians mr. faroush the point
was the European Union had introduced a
refugee policy that said anybody that
set foot on European soil regardless
where they come from would be allowed to
stay it was total and utter madness and
very very few but the UK government
wouldn't have let them all in mr.
Farraday or but they all would have had
you they all have had EU passports and
you know within the space of a few years
wouldn't they that's the point
and actually that decision by Merkel is
fundamentally changing European politics
um he's going to look at you when you're
85 years old in your in need of care
somebody who is trained to do it well
under this new system there'll be a lot
of people who M be as fortunate as you
are the care sector for example says if
there'll be a shortage in the next video
what luckily luckily that is 30 years
away that problem as far as I wait for
you but the point is that there'll be
people over the next two three four five
you know they won't receive anything
because this is one a care sector I'm
not saying that Mr Farage this is the
care industry before they value shortage
of star before 2004 before we had an
open door to 8 and then 10 former
communist countries the elderly got
looked after hotels ran and strawberries
didn't rot in the fields and just
because we've had this flood of cheap
labour since 2004 I think what what
needs to happen here is some of the big
employers need to recognize that their
days of employing cheap labour which may
be good for them but not so good for the
communities in into which people come
that is finished and and and that is
some of the government's done today but
you didn't answer my question who's
going to look after the elder
in the next five years who invest what
lead of care as I say the elderly will
get looked after the fruit will gain the
hotels will and the buses will run and
you know these are scare stories we have
we have left the European Union the
government is now in control of
immigration of work permits of all of
those things and I've no doubt there'll
be adjustments that happen every single
year but they're not scare stories are
there Mr Farage I mean these are people
who work in the scare in the care sector
these are people who work in the
hospitality sector yeah the experts
they're the ones they're the ones that
want cheap labour that's that's been the
benefit the benefit has been for big
employers they've got cheap labour and
as a result of that we've actually seen
productivity in the United Kingdom going
down the model has changed the
government has given us an intention of
that today that is a step in the right
direction but ultimately what the public
will want is to see lower numbers and we
haven't got there yet and what are your
plans now Mr Farage EU planning to
bowels for politics well I'm obviously
going to keep a watching brief on what
happens with breakfast in I mean back in
2017 I listened to Theresa May and I
really believed her when she gave the
Lancaster House speech only to be
completely let down at this moment in
time I am delighted with what David
Frost the government's chief negotiator
said in Brussels two nights ago you know
we're heading in the right direction but
I will be keeping a watching brief just
in case it goes wrong again one of the
stories that were looking at today is
this debates by the algún marbles Mr
Farage I mean what are your thoughts on
that my thoughts are that if we hadn't
been looking after the Elgin marbles
they probably would have been destroyed
over the course of the last few decades
so I you know I understand the Rao but
but to be honest with you I think Greece
had got rather bigger problems to worry
about than the Elgin marbles okay Nigel
Farage appreciate your time this morning
thank you